Donald Trump is withdrawing at the
United States from the United Nations
Human Rights Council this was announced
by US ambassador to the UN nikki Haley
this is of course in addition to Donald
Trump polling the United States out of
the Paris climate Accords pulling the
u.s. out of the Iran deal cooling or
destroying alliances with many long-term
American friends and this is actually a
complicated one you might remember that
the United Nations Human Rights Council
has become significantly jeopardized
it's often had a massive loss of
credibility because of the inclusion of
for example Saudi Arabia on the Human
Rights Council how on earth
literally we're talking about the UN and
and countries on earth how on earth can
you justify putting Saudi Arabia which
beheads people publicly completely
subjugates women is one of the most
extreme religious theocracies in the
world how do you put them on a council
called the Human Rights Council so there
is no question that this is a
beleaguered Commission but what does it
mean for the United States to pull out
that's what I want to think about nikki
Haley says the u.s. is pulling out
because the UN Human Rights Council is
biased against Israel and fails to hold
human rights abusers accountable I agree
I'm glad it's being said but that
doesn't mean the United States should
leave the Commission because first of
all given that the concerns about the
Commission are real ones if the u.s.
leaves that's a voice that could push
back against the actions of the
Commission that is self selecting out
you would be much more effective at
changing the council if that's what you
want to do by working from within it
than by throwing stones from the outside
secondly the timing of this decision
confirms that Nikki Haley's explanation
is actually BS because nikki Haley is
saying that the bias against Israel and
not holding human rights abusers
accountable are the reasons why the
United States is pulling out but it just
so happened that the announcement was
made the day after the UN High
Commissioners Office for Human Rights
slammed
what the United States has been doing at
the us-mexico border in separating from
families and putting in internment camps
and cages little kids so if the reason
was anti-israeli bias or failure to hold
human rights abusers accountable why are
they only making this decision 24 hours
after there was a UN criticism about the
border situation for me the explanation
although accurate has no credibility as
the real reason why nikki Haley is
making this announcement and then the
last thing my thought my mind went to
when I was thinking about this is that
if the United States is so upset about
the UN failing to hold human rights
abusers accountable then Trump should be
slamming Saudi Arabia rather than doing
arm deals with them
. end of story the Trump administration
cannot possibly have credibility on this
issue of human rights since they do
business with one of the top human
rights abusers of Saudi Arabia so I
don't disagree for a second about the
concerns that nikki Haley stated but
pulling out for these reasons and with
this timing is both hypocritical
dishonest and completely
counterproductive and for context no
member nation has ever voluntarily left
the Human Rights Council there have been
people kicked out countries kicked out
but trumpets are going to frame this as
some kind of Maverick move that's
standing up for America it's actually
the United States joining not the
greatest list of colleagues that are no
longer part of this Council after having
been on it yeah sure it may be a bad
look to pull out of a Human Rights
Council but can we just renegotiate get
a better deal get a better Commission
it's funny how everything Trump was
going to renegotiate he's just burning
down in flames and then not actually
fixing or recreating and if you look at
the other countries that refuse to
participate from the beginning in this
it's Iran and North Korea and Eritrea
that is the list of countries that the
United States is sort of adding its name
to change my mind if I'm wrong I'm open
to having my mind changed I think that
this was the wrong move for the United
States to make